For thousands of years, people have turned to religion to answer questions about how to lead a happy, moral, and fulfilling life, how to meet life's challenges, and how to be resilient in the face of hardship. And for many people, religion's answers have proven satisfying. A 2019 Pew Research poll found that people who described themselves as actively religious, those who were affiliated with a religion and attended religious services regularly, were more likely to say that they were very happy than people who didn't go to services or who were unaffiliated with any organized religion. Why is that?
几千年来，人们一直求助于宗教，以寻求关于如何过上幸福、道德和充实的生活、如何应对生活挑战以及如何在逆境中保持韧性的答案。对许多人来说，宗教的答案已被证明是令人满意的。皮尤研究中心2019年的一项民意调查发现，那些自称积极信教的人，即那些有宗教信仰并定期参加宗教仪式的人，比那些不参加仪式或没有任何宗教信仰的人更有可能表示自己非常幸福。这是为什么呢？
How do the structures and traditions of religion contribute to people's health, happiness, and well-being? What can behavioral scientists learn from studying the religious rituals that scaffold people's lives from birth to coming of age to marriage to death? And can those lessons be applied outside the context? of religious belief. What about the perennial question that pits science against religion? Can one be a scientist
宗教的结构和传统如何促进人们的健康、幸福和福祉？行为科学家能从研究那些支撑人们从出生、成年礼、结婚到死亡等人生阶段的宗教仪式中学到什么？这些经验能应用于宗教信仰之外的语境吗？那么那个让科学与宗教对立的永恒问题呢？一个人可以既是科学家，
and still believe in a higher power? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. David Destano,
又相信有更高的力量吗？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是大卫·德斯塔诺博士，
a professor of psychology at Northeastern University in Boston, where he directs the social emotions lab. Dr. Dosteno studies the ways in which people's emotions influence their social behavior and moral decision-making in areas including trust, altruism, cooperation, resilience, dishonesty, and prejudice. In recent years, he's been particularly interested in what behavioral science can learn from religious traditions about how to help people improve their well-being and lead happier lives. He explores this topic in his book, How God's a Life, How God's,
他是波士顿东北大学的心理学教授，在那里他负责社会情感实验室。德斯塔诺博士研究人们的情感如何影响他们在信任、利他主义、合作、韧性、不诚实和偏见等领域的社会行为和道德决策。近年来，他特别感兴趣的是行为科学能从宗教传统中学到什么，以帮助人们改善福祉并过上更幸福的生活。他在九月份出版的著作《上帝如何运作：宗教益处背后的科学》以及同名播客中探讨了这个话题。感谢您的加入，德斯塔诺博士。你好，金。谢谢你邀请我。许多关于科学与宗教的讨论都以冲突为框架，认为这是看待世界的两种对立方式。但在你的书中，你认为科学家可以从研究宗教中学到很多东西，尤其是行为科学家。那么让我们从他们开始吧。作为一名研究心理学家，是什么激发了你对宗教的兴趣，并让你决定这正是你需要研究的东西？是的，谢谢你的提问。
works, the science behind the benefits of religion, published in September, and in a podcast by the same name, which debuted in September. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Distan. Hi, Kim. Thank you for having me on. Many discussions of science and religion are framed in terms of conflict, that these are two opposing ways of looking at the world. But in your book, you argue that scientists can learn a great deal from studying religion, particularly behavioral scientists. So let's start with them As a research psychologist, what sparked your interest in religion and made you decide that it was something you needed to study? Yeah, thank you for that question.
我想明确一点，我在这方面没有预设议程。我开始这项工作并不是为了证明宗教对人们是有益还是有害的。我只是像任何优秀的科学家一样，简单地遵循数据。在我的实验室里，我们长期研究人们如何变得更加善良和富有同情心，如何建立联系，如何变得更有韧性。每当我们发现某种新的机制、策略或生活小窍门来帮助实现这一点时，我环顾四周，就会发现它们被用于各种宗教仪式中。我终于有一名学生对冥想本身非常感兴趣。根据佛教徒的说法，它最初的神学目的不是为了提高你的记忆力，也不是为了提高你的标准化考试成绩，而是为了减少所有众生的痛苦。因此，我们进行了一些研究，实际上证明了在八周的冥想之后，人们变得更加自发地善良。也就是说，我们使用演员，让他们看起来很痛苦并需要帮助。我们发现，与随机对照组相比，参与冥想的人突然变得更愿意帮助他们。所以我开始意识到，我们正在做的很多工作，我们正在研究的很多机制，
I want to be clear that I didn't have an agenda in this. I didn't start out on this line of work to prove religion was beneficial or harmful to people. I just simply followed the data like any good scientist. And for a long time in my lab, we study things like how people become more kind and compassionate, how they form connection, how they become more resilient. And every time we would find some new mechanism or some new strategy or life hack to help this, I'd look around and see it being used in all types of religious rituals. And I finally had one student who was very much interested in meditation itself. And what its original theological purpose was according to the Buddhists,
很久以前就被宗教思想家直觉地发现了。对于科学家来说，这很令人谦卑，对吧？当有人有了你的想法时，这已经足够令人谦卑了，但当他们比你早几千年想到这一点时，这真的让人感到谦卑。而且，你知道，我不认为我们会从宗教中了解太多关于宇宙本质或疾病生物学的知识。但如果几千年来旨在帮助人们应对生活挑战的思想却一无是处，那才奇怪。所以我用的类比是，你知道，有时当制药公司寻找药物来帮助人们时，他们会求助于传统文化。当然，传统文化使用的许多药物可能没有帮助，但有些确实有。我们通过这些检查发现了治疗不同类型癌症和其他疾病的绝妙药物。我认为当涉及到心理学和人类福祉时，我们也应该这样做。你知道，我们在冥想方面已经做了一点。我们知道它能减轻压力和焦虑，但正念不可能是唯一能提供帮助的精神技巧。所以我在这里的论点是，让我们把我们的“主义”放在一边。
which is not to improve your memory, not to raise your standardized test scores, but to reduce the suffering of all sentient beings. And so we ran some studies where we actually show that after eight weeks of meditation, people became more spontaneously kind. That is, we would use actors and have them looking like they were in pain and needing help. And we would find people who were engaged in meditation compared to randomized controls would suddenly become more willing to help them. And so what I began to realize is a lot of the work we were doing, a lot of the mechanisms we were studying,
我们无法回答“上帝是否存在”这个问题。任何值得尊重的科学家都会告诉你，你知道，他们可能看不到证据，但他们无法证明上帝不存在的终局。所以我们不要争论那个。让我们尊重每个人的观点，把这些放在一边，专注于我们可以关注的事情，那就是这些实践如何让人们的生活变得更好，我们可以从中汲取什么知识，什么智慧？你书中的核心主题之一是仪式的力量。首先，你如何定义宗教仪式，是什么让它区别于任何其他类型的习惯仪式？
have been intuitive by religious thinkers long ago. For scientists, that's humbling, right? It's always when someone has your idea, that's humbling enough but when they beat you to it by thousands of years. It's really humbling. And, you know, I don't think we're going to learn much about the nature of the cosmos or the biology of disease from religion. But it would be strange if thousands of years of thought meant to help people meet the
为什么仪式本质上如此强大？这是一个非常好的问题。你知道，宗教思想家长期以来一直试图定义仪式，很难根据一组特定的动作来定义仪式，因为有时这些动作是仪式的一部分，有时则不是。我的意思是，为了能更好地看清食物而点蜡烛，与为了安息日或其他宗教目的而点蜡烛有什么区别？你知道，你做的是同样的动作。所以，真正最好的定义是，仪式是带着特殊意图完成的动作。除此之外，
challenges of life didn't have something to offer. And so the analogy I use is, you know, sometimes when pharmaceutical companies are looking for medications to help people, they will look to traditional cultures. And sure, a lot of those medications that traditional cultures use might not help, but some do. And we found wonderful medications to treat different types of cancer and other ailments from those examinations. I think we should do the same when it comes to psychology and human well-being. You know, we've done that a little bit with meditation. We know it reduces stress and anxiety, but mindfulness can't be the only spiritual technique that has something to offer. And so my argument here is let's put our isms aside.
没有太多东西能将它们结合在一起。你知道，有时人们同步进行。有时他们唱歌。并不总是这样。有时他们吟唱。并不总是这样。有时是独自一人。有时是一起。
We can't answer the question, does God exist? Any scientist worth their thought will tell you, you know, they may see no evidence of it, but they can't prove the finality that God doesn't exist. So let's not argue about that. Let's respect everybody's views, put those to the side and focus on what we can focus on, which is how these practices make life better for people and what knowledge, what wisdom can we take from that? One of the central themes of your book is the power of ritual. First of all, how do you define a religious ritual and what makes it different from any other type of habit ritual?
但真正重要的是，这是一个带有某种意图和特殊目的的动作。但宗教仪式背后最精彩的地方在于它们现在的存在方式，你可以把它们看作是利用我们思想和身体的机制。我们在许多仪式中总是看到的一件事是人们齐心协力地做事情。你知道，我们会齐声站立和跪下。我们会齐声唱歌或吟唱。嗯，我的实验室和其他人的研究表明，当人们齐心协力做事情时，
And why essentially are rituals so powerful? That's a really good question. You know, religious thinkers for a long time have been trying to define. rituals and it's hard to define a ritual based on a certain set of actions because sometimes those actions are part of rituals, sometimes they're not. I mean, what's the difference between lighting a candle so I can see my food better versus lighting a candle for Shabbat or for some other religious purpose? You know, you're doing the same action. And so really, the best definition out there is that rituals are actions that are done with a special intention. And besides that,
即使他们只是同步地移动手臂，也会让他们感到更紧密、更富有同情心，并且更有可能互相帮助。我们知道，当你吟唱、念玫瑰经或唱印度教基尔坦时，它会降低你的呼吸频率。通过降低呼吸频率，它会减慢心率，然后通过迷走神经向你的大脑发出信号，表明这是一个安全的环境，一个更能建立联系的环境。所以你看到的是，这些机制以一种并非
there's not much that combines them all. You know, sometimes people do them in synchrony. Sometimes they sing. Not always. Sometimes they chant. Not always. Sometimes it's alone. Sometimes it's together.
我们关注的随机行为的方式打包在一起，但实际上它们作用于我们的生理机能和大脑的隐藏语言，以实现特定的目标。所以宗教仪式的美妙之处在于，它不仅仅是说，“让我们点燃一支蜡烛，我们要说这个行为很特别。”而是他们随着时间的推移直觉地发现了操纵我们生理和思维的方法，以帮助实现他们想要的目标。所以，你知道，我听到的最好的术语之一是，你可以把仪式看作是“调试过的技术”。
But really what it is is an action that has some intention and special purpose attached to it. But what is brilliant behind religious rituals in the way they exist now is you can think about them as mechanisms that leverage our mind and our body. One thing we always see in. in many rituals are people doing things in unison. You know, we will stand and kneel in unison. We will sing or chant in unison. Well, there's work from my lab and others that shows when people do things in unison,
几千年来，它们经过磨练，对我们的思想和身体产生影响，利用我们的生理机能，帮助我们将思想推向我们在该仪式中想要实现的目标。你围绕人类生命周期安排了你的书，并讨论了不同的宗教传统如何在人们生命的不同时期帮助他们，从出生到童年，到青春期的成年礼，再到成年，最后是死亡和哀悼。你研究过哪些在这些不同时期帮助人们的更引人注目的仪式例子？
even if they simply move their arms in time in unison with each other, it makes them feel more connected, more compassionate, and more likely to help each other. We know that when you chant or when you say the rosary or sing Hindu kirton, it reduces your breathing rate. And by reducing your respiration rate, it slows your heart rate, which then through the vagus nerve singles to your mind that this is a safe environment, one that's more able for connection. And so what you're seeing is these mechanisms are packaged together in ways that aren't
让我，是的，让我从结尾开始，因为对我来说，在某种意义上，那是我所见过的最引人注目的例子之一。正如你所说，这本书是沿着生命之路展开的。我试图审视这些仪式中的趋同点，因为在某种意义上，你提到的那些人生道路上的事情是我们所有人都会面临的共同点。但是，是否有些人因为某种原因，拥有稍微更好一点的仪式元素组合？如果你考虑悲伤和失落，你知道，无论你在生活中是谁，你很可能会遇到失去所爱之人的时刻。在这种情况下，所有宗教仪式都会做的一件事就是我们都会悼念逝者，
just random acts that we give attention to, but that actually work on our physiology and the mind's hidden language to accomplish certain goals. And so the beauty about religious rituals, it's not just saying, let's just light a candle and this act we're going to say is special. But they've intuited over time ways to manipulate our physiology and our thinking to help achieve the goal that they want. And so, you know, one of the best terms I've heard is you can think about the rituals as debugged technologies.
这看起来很正常，因为我们都这样做。但如果你从心理学角度考虑，起初这有点奇怪。如果我刚刚失去了一份我非常热爱的工作，或者如果我深爱的妻子刚刚决定要和我离婚，我不会想去想那份工作或我的妻子，因为思考我所失去的东西会使痛苦加剧。然而，当有人去世时，我们总是这样做。心理学家乔治·博纳诺（George Bonano）——他是世界上领先的丧亲研究人员之一——有非常棒的新研究，相对较新的研究，他表明，能够巩固逝者积极记忆的人，能以更具韧性的方式度过悲伤。
Over the millennia, they've been honed to have effects on our mind and body, to leverage our physiology, to help us nudge our minds toward the, goals we want to achieve in that ritual. You arranged your book around the human life cycle and discuss how different religious traditions can help people at different times in their lives, from birth to childhood, to coming of age rituals and adolescence to adulthood and finally death and mourning. What are some of the more compelling examples of rituals you looked at that help people at these different times?
我的意思是，在更短的时间内，且伴随着较少的衰弱性焦虑或抑郁。但最重要的是，如果你看看某些仪式，甚至还有其他打包在里面的元素。我最喜欢的一个是犹太人的“坐七”（Shiva）仪式。如果你没有参加过“坐七”，会发生很多事情，但这是一个为期七天的哀悼期。首先是真的，它被称为“米茨瓦”（mitzvah），这是一种神圣的义务。当有人去世时，你必须去他们家。你必须给他们带食物。你必须拜访他们。你必须帮助他们。这提供了心理学中所说的“工具性支持”，这是帮助人们度过悲伤的主要预测因素之一。
Let me, yeah, let me start with the end, because to me in some sense, that is some of the most compelling that I have seen. So as you say, the book is laid out along the path of life. And I try to look at both the convergences in these rituals, because in some senses, those things that you mentioned on the road of life are commonalities we all face. But then do some face, for whatever reason, have slightly potentially better packages of ritual elements. So if you think about grief and loss, you know, it's something no matter who you are in life, you're going to come to that time when you lose somebody you love likely. And one thing that all religious rituals do in that instance is we all eulogize the person who has passed,
这不是在Facebook上给他们点赞或发信息。而是在需要的时候出现。所以它确保社区这样做，并且在几天内反复这样做。在“坐七”期间，家里的镜子会被遮住。这看起来可能有点奇怪，而且有神学原因。但也有心理学研究表明，当你照镜子时，你感受到的任何情绪都会被放大。所以如果你感到快乐，你会变得更快乐。
which seems kind of normal because we all do it. But if you think about it psychologically, it's kind of odd at first. If I just lost a job that I really love or if my wife, who I dearly love just decided she was going to divorce me, I wouldn't want to think about that job or my wife because thinking about what I've lost would make the pain that much worse. Yet it's something we always do when somebody passes. And there's wonderful new research, relatively new research by the psychologist George Bonano, who's one of the leading bereavement researchers in the world, who shows that it's people who can consolidate positive memories of the deceased who pass through grief more resiliently.
感到悲伤，你会变得更悲伤。或者在悲伤的时候，那意味着更多的悲伤。所以通过遮住镜子，你所做的是稍微减少悲伤。你坐在低处，或者坐在低矮的椅子上，或者坐在地上。有新的神经科学研究表明，嗯，如果你坐在低处，从人体工程学上讲，那会开始导致下背部和膝盖的不适。然后当你站起来迎接人们时，它就消失了。有新的神经科学研究表明，当你出现轻微的开始和结束的不适时，
And by that, I mean, in a quicker time and with less debilitating anxiety or depression. But on top of that, if you look at certain rituals, there's even, other elements that are packaged in. One of my favorite is the Jewish ritual of sitting Shiva. So if you haven't been to Shiva, many things happen, but it's a seven-day period of morning. And the first thing that is true is it is called a mitzvote, which is a sacred obligation. When someone passes, you must go to their house. You must bring them food. You must visit them. You must help them out. That's providing what's called in psychology instrumental support, which is one of the leading predictors of helping people through grief.
像那样，它会减少反刍和悲伤。人们聚在一起，以10人一组，称为“米尼安”（minion），10人或更多，一起祈祷并吟唱，一起背诵。在那里，你再次看到了那种同步性的发生，我们有实验证据表明，这种同步性增加了同情心和互相帮助的意愿。所以这只是一个例子，但你可以看到，这些不是随机的元素。它们通过时代，已经找出了对思想和身体的某些推动力，帮助我们应对我们面临的任何挑战。所以你写到那些不信教的人
It's not giving them a like or a message on Facebook. It's showing up when you're needed. And so it makes sure that the community does this and repeatedly for a period of days. Mirrors are covered in a household during Shiva. It might seem kind of strange and there's a theological reason for it. But there's also psychological research that shows when you look into a mirror, whatever emotion you are feeling becomes amplified. So if you're feeling happy, you get happier.
可以从世俗仪式中获得心理益处。如果有人，比如说，加入合唱团或管弦乐队，或者加入垒球队，甚至成为一名共济会成员，效果是一样的吗？例如，是否有类似于从本质上一起表演所获得的心理和生理益处？这就是你刚才谈到的。是的。所以，这有两部分。一是，你知道，人们经常说，嗯，这些不是宗教的好处吗？为了清楚起见，你知道，除了你提到的皮尤的研究之外，梅奥诊所的研究和哈佛人类繁荣项目中心的研究表明，那些参与信仰活动的人，不仅仅是说“我相信”，
feeling sad, you become sad. Or at a time of grief, that would mean more grief. So by covering the mirrors, what you're doing is reducing grief a bit. You sit low to the ground or on low chairs or on the ground. There's new neuroscience research that shows, well, if you sit low to the ground, ergonomically, that's going to start to cause discomfort in your lower back and knees. And then when you get up to welcome people, it goes away. There's new neuroscience research that shows when you have mild onsets and offsets of discomfort
而是实际上定期参与信仰活动，预示着更低的死亡率、更好的心血管健康、更好的心理健康，以及所有这类事情。所以作为一名科学家，这告诉我，他们所做的事情很重要。正如你所建议的那样，人们经常说的一件事是，这不就是聚在一起吗？当然，社区对人类的福祉很重要。孤独对心理和身体健康都很糟糕。但数据表明，这些好处不仅仅是你加入任何俱乐部所能得到的。我认为这是因为在这些信仰传统中，还有其他将人们聚集在一起的实践。
like that, it reduces rumination and grief. People come together and in groups of 10 called a minion, 10 or more, to say prayers together and chant them to recite them together. Again, there you see that synchrony happening, synchrony that we know we have experimental evidence that increases feelings of compassion willing to help each other. And so this is just one example, but what you can see is these aren't random elements. They, through the ages, have figured out certain nudges to the mind and the body that help us deal with whatever challenge we're facing. So you write about how people who are not religious
我们可以谈谈，你知道，更多关于它们的事情。但我刚才说的那个仪式例子，不仅把人们聚集在一起，还建立了那种社区感和信仰感。所以，是的，如果你参与像同步这样的行动，就像我刚才说的那样。所以与其一起祈祷或一起吟唱，不如一起体验其他情绪，这会让你感到彼此更亲近。我的实验室有数据表明这一点。但数据也表明，当你加上这些信仰等其他元素时，
can derive psychological benefits from secular rituals. Are the effects the same if someone, say, joins a chorus or an orchestra or joins a softball team or even becomes a mason, for example, are there psychological and physiological benefits that are similar to those that are derived from essentially performing together? That's what you were just talking about. Yeah. So, there are two parts to that. One is, you know, people often say, well, aren't these benefits of religion? And just to be clear, you know, besides the work you mentioned from Pew, there's research from the Mayo Clinic and research from the Harvard Center for Human Flourishing Program showing that people who engage in the activities of their faith, not just saying, I believe,
效果会更强。所以我们并不真正知道整体上强多少。所以我现在能说的最好的是，如果你以一种非常世俗的方式进行这些仪式，你会从中受益。如果你加上信仰的多层方面，这种好处是否与你所能得到的一模一样？我们不能确定。所以，不是为了轻率，但如果我，比如说，在合唱团唱威尔第的《安魂曲》，会有什么不同吗？
but actually engaging regularly in the activities of their faith, predicts lower mortality, better cardiovascular health, better mental health, all types of things like that. So as a scientist, what that tells me is something that they're doing matters. And one thing that people often say, as you suggested, well, isn't it just coming together? And sure, community is an important part of well-being for humans. Being lonely is terrible for mental and physical well-being. But the data suggests that the benefits are more than just what you get from joining into any club. And I think that's because in these faith traditions, there are these other practices that bring people together.
而不是唱《音乐之声》？因为它是非世俗音乐，我会得到不同的好处吗？在这种情况下，我不这么认为。但有些仪式中，信仰元素非常重要。例如，如果我们看看治疗仪式，对吧？我们知道安慰剂效应非常强大。事实上，它占任何药物治疗效果的约30%。而且，你知道，人们听到安慰剂效应这个想法。
And we can talk, you know, more about them. But that example of rituals I just said that not only bring people together, but build that sense of community and belief. And so, yes, if you engage in actions like synchrony, like I was saying. So rather than saying prayers together or chanting together, do other emotions together, that will make you feel closer to one another. we have data in my lab to show that. But the data also suggests that when you add on these other elements of belief, et cetera,
他们认为这是一种贬义或嘲讽的东西。但实际上并非如此。它是身体自我修复的证据。医生们一直在使用它。因此，有极好的证据表明，对某事物的信仰及其治愈你的能力实际上可以解释很大一部分正在发生的治愈。事实上，有一些令人惊奇的事情，甚至被称为“开放标签安慰剂”，即安慰剂对你有效，即使你知道它们是安慰剂，如果你相信安慰剂效应的话。所以我认为信仰真正做的是
that the effects are stronger. So we don't really know how much stronger overall. So the best that I can say right now is if you do these rituals in a very secular way, you will get benefits from them. Is the benefit exactly equivalent to what you would get if you have on, if you add on the multi-layered aspects of belief? We don't know that for sure. So not to be flippant, but is there a difference if I'm, say, in a chorus singing the Verdi Requiem
从心理学角度来看，它设定了你大脑对将要发生的事情的期望和预测。无论你将这种发生归因于神灵的影响，还是归因于对其他事物力量的信仰，在它将如何影响你的身体方面并不重要。但我认为信仰的那个元素是你比仅仅通过呼吸或唱歌的动作本身能获得更强好处的地方。所以刚才你谈到了一点关于冥想，对吧？这是一种被科学家研究过的宗教实践。
versus singing the sound of music? Would I be getting different benefits because it's non-secular music? In that case, I don't think so. But there are certain rituals where the belief element is strongly important. So, for example, one area is if we look at healing rituals, right? We know that the placebo effect is very powerful. In fact, it accounts for about 30% of therapeutic effect of any medication. And, you know, people hear the idea of the placebo effect.
但它也进入了世俗世界。关于冥想的科学发现如何符合传统宗教对冥想目的的理解？是的。所以，你知道，冥想已经被科学地研究了，你知道，一二十年了。其中很多实际上是因为达赖喇嘛本人对科学研究非常开放，并实际上资助了很多研究。但最初，它被认知神经科学家所采用，他们对它对你的大脑有什么作用感兴趣。所以，你知道，我们发现了美妙的事情。冥想实际上改变了你大脑的物理结构。它增加了你的记忆力。
They think of that as kind of a derogatory thing or a derisive thing. But it's actually not. It's the evidence of the body to heal itself. And physicians have been using this forever. And so there's wonderful evidence suggesting that belief in something and its ability to heal you can actually account for a good deal of the healing that goes on. In fact, there's something amazing that even called open label placebos, which are, plasibos work for you, even when you know they're placebo, if you believe in the placebo effect. And so I think what belief really does
它增加了你拥有注意力、集中注意力的能力。它减轻了压力。但如果你像我一样与僧侣和佛教喇嘛交谈，他们会告诉你，是的，它会减轻你的压力。是的，它会增加你的记忆力。但那不是它的目的，对吧？那些事情是顺便发生的。它的目的是作为一种减少所有众生痛苦的工具。那就是你自己，通过冥想，当你抑郁减少、焦虑减少时，你受的苦就更少，
from a psychological standpoint is it sets your mind's expectations and predictions about what's going to be, what's going to happen. Whether you ascribe that happening to the influence of a divine being, or whether you ascribe that happening to the belief of the power of something else doesn't matter in the sense of how it's going to affect your body. But I think that element of belief is where you can get a stronger benefit than just the actions of the breathing or singing on its own. So a few moments ago you were talking a little bit about meditation of, right? It's a religious practice that's been studied by scientists.
等等。但它也被设计用来唤醒人们这种同情心和帮助其他有需要的人的意愿。令人惊讶的是，从来没有人研究过这一点。所以我们决定认真对待它。因此，我们进行了一项研究，我们从波士顿地区带来了从未冥想过但有兴趣开始的人。我们让他们要么冥想八周，在那里他们接受了佛教喇嘛的培训，要么我们把他们放在候补名单上。所以两组人对冥想同样感兴趣，他们都没有冥想过。
But it's also moved into the secular world as well. How do the scientific findings about meditation fit into the traditional religious understanding of the purpose of meditation? Yeah. So, you know, meditation has been being studied scientifically for, you know, a decade or two now. And a lot of that actually happened because the Dalai Lama himself is very open to scientific study of it and actually funded a lot of research. But initially, it was picked up by cognitive neuroscientists who were interested in what does it do to your brain. And so, you know, we found out wonderful things. Meditation actually alters the physical structure of your brain. It increases your memory.
一组接受了治疗，一组接受了干预，一组没有。在那八周结束时，我们一次一个地把他们带到我们的实验室，告诉他们我们要给你做一些记忆测试。那不是真的。当他们到达实验室时，真正的实验发生在候诊室。在候诊室里，有三把椅子，其中两把被我们雇佣的演员占据，我们的参与者不知道这一点。当参与者进来时，他们当然会占据第三把也是最后一把剩下的椅子。大约两分钟后，另一名演员进来了，她拄着拐杖，
It increases your ability to have attention, focus your attention. It reduces stress. But if you talk to the monks like I have and the Buddhist lamas, what they'll tell you is, yes, it will reduce your stress. Yes, it will increase your memory. But that is not its purpose, right? those things happen along the way. Its purpose is as a tool to reduce the suffering of all sentient beings. That is yourself, through meditation, you suffer less as you have less depression, less anxiety,
脚上穿着那种脚骨折时穿的靴子。它没有骨折。但她会假装她很痛苦，畏缩着进来，没有座位。当然，其他演员被告知要刷手机并无视她。问题是，真正的研究参与者会做什么？我们发现，平均而言，只有约15%没有冥想的人决定站起来把座位让给她。你可能会说，嗯，那太糟糕了。但你在地铁或公共汽车上经常看到这种情况，对吧？
etc. But it also is designed to awaken in people this sense of compassion and willing to help other individuals who are in need. And so surprisingly, no one had ever looked at that. And so we decided to take that seriously. And so we conducted a study where we brought people from the Boston area who had never meditated before, but were interested in starting. And we assigned them to either meditate for eight weeks where they had training with the Buddhist Lama or we put them on a wait list. So two groups that were equally interested in meditation, none of whom had meditated before.
人们只是，他们转身，哦，是的，我不让座。有一个带着蹒跚学步孩子的妈妈或一个痛苦的人。但在冥想者中，50%的人这样做了。现在，那是三倍的差异，这非常巨大。我们已经重复了这项研究，所以我们知道这不是侥幸。这告诉我们，佛教的想法是对的。仅仅参与这种冥想练习，在八周的时间之后，实际上增加了人们的同情心。
One got treatment, one got the intervention, one didn't. And at the end of those eight weeks, we bring them into our lab one at a time telling them we're going to give you some memory tests. That wasn't true. When they got to the lab, the real experiment took place in the waiting room. And in the waiting room, there were three chairs, two of which were occupied by actors that we hired, which our participants didn't know. When the participant came in, they'd, of course, take the third and last remaining chair. About two minutes later, another actor came in, and she was on crutches,
我们已经进行了后续研究，我们通过长期的恶作剧，我不会用它来让你感到厌烦。我们让人们实际上被演员侮辱，方式通常会让他们非常生气。然后我们给他们一种他们认为可以对这个人进行报复的方式。当然，他们不能真正做到，但他们认为他们可以。我们发现，你知道，在冥想了许多周之后，人们减少了他们想要对这个侮辱他们的人进行的报复。他们不会因挑衅而产生攻击性。所以这告诉我们，你知道，这里有一些真理。而且，你知道，我在我的实验室里研究的没有什么比感恩的作用这个概念更重要的了。
wearing one of those boots on her foot that you wear when your foot is broken. It wasn't broken. But she would pretend she's in pain and wince and come in and there is no seats. And of course, the other actors were told to thumb their phones and ignore her. And the question was, what would the true research participants do? And what we found is that on average, only about 15% of the people who didn't meditate decided to get up and give them her chair. And you might say, well, that's pretty terrible. But you see this on the subway or the bus all the time, right?
我们一次又一次地发现，当人们通过向神表达对他们所拥有的东西的感激，向朋友、家人、命运，无论它可能是什么，来感到感激时，我们发现这使他们更慷慨。它使他们更有耐心。它使他们更愿意分享他们所拥有的东西并信任其他人，而不仅仅是他们感激的人，任何人。如果你看看宗教，对吧，每个宗教都有培养感恩的方法。基督徒在吃饭时会做感恩祈祷。犹太人每天早上起床。他们会说“Moda Ani”祈祷，这是对上帝感谢我回到这个地球
People just, they turn, oh, yeah, I don't give it my seat. There's a mom with a toddler in tow or a person in pain. But among the meditators, 50% did. Now, that's a threefold difference, which is huge. And we've replicated the study so we know it's not a fluke. And what this tells us is the Buddhist idea was right. Just engaging in this meditation practice after this, you know, eight weeks of time actually increased people's compassion.
又一天，等等。所以关于宗教有趣的事情是，任何行为科学家都会告诉你，我们都有意图。我们都有我们想做的事情，比如在这种情况下成为一个更好的人。但除非我们有策略或工具，否则我们无法到达那里。关于新年决心，对吧？到一月中旬，25%的人失败了。到年底，只有8%的人一直坚持到底。我们需要工具来帮助我们实现目标。宗教在这些仪式中所做的不仅仅是告诉我们我们应该是什么样，而是给我们
We've done subsequent studies where we have, through long shenanigans, I'm not going to bore you with. we have people actually get insulted by actors in a way that usually makes them pretty angry. And then we give them a way that they think they can seek vengeance on this person. Of course, they can't really do it, but they think they can. And what we find is that, you know, after so in many weeks of meditation, people reduce the vengeance they want to take on this person who insulted them. They don't rise with aggression to provocation. And so what this tells us is that, you know, there is some truth here. And, you know, nothing we work on in my lab is this notion of what gratitude does.
工具，使我们更有可能成为那样的人。所以冥想听起来有点神奇。你谈到了寻找下一次冥想。如果冥想本身那么好，为什么我们需要下一次冥想？我们在寻找什么？当你那样说时，你是什么意思？是的，我的意思是。所以冥想是变得更善良的绝佳工具，对吧？变得更富有同情心。
And we found time and again that when people feel grateful by expressing their gratitude to God for what they have, to friends, family, to fate, whatever it might be, we find that it makes them more generous. It makes them more patient. It makes them more willing to share what they have and trust other people and not just the people to whom they're grateful, anybody. And if you look at religions, right, every religion has ways to foster gratitude. Christians say prayers of grace when they eat. Jews every day in the morning they get up. They say the moda-ani prayer, which is a thank you to God for returning me to this earth
但生活中还有其他我们想做的事情，对吧？我怎样才能变得更快乐？所以，是的，冥想会减少焦虑、抑郁，但它能帮助你找到人生的意义吗？不完全是。所以人们做的另一件事，你知道，如果你看看整个生命周期的幸福感，它往往会在40岁和50岁左右下降到最低点，然后开始上升。而且，有心理学家劳拉·卡尔森（Laura Carlson）的极好证据表明，随着人们年龄的增长，他们将欲望从在生活中取得领先、建立技能、你知道，
for another day, et cetera. And so the interesting thing about religion is any behavioral scientist will tell you, we all have intentions. We all have things that we want to do, like in this case be a better person. But unless we have strategies or tools, we don't get there. about New Year's resolutions, right? By mid-January, 25% have failed. By the end of the year, only 8% have been kept all the way through. We need tools to help us reach our goals. And what religions are doing in these rituals is not just telling us how we should be, but giving us the
建立地位，转向关注朋友、家人和服务，这些实际上已被证明能带来更多生活幸福的事情。但虽然它看起来像是年龄的函数，但她的工作真正表明的是，它是她所说的“时间跨度”的函数，也就是我离死亡还有多久。所以你在她的工作和其他人的工作中看到的是，在像我们现在都面临的流行病期间，那种年龄差异消失了，因为突然间，即使是年轻人，即使是二三十岁的人也在想，我可能没有剩下多少时间了。突然间，他们看起来像老年人。他们重视朋友、家人，通过服务在生活中寻找意义。
tools to make it more likely that we can be that way. So meditation sounds kind of magical. And you have talked about finding the next meditation. If meditation itself is so great, why do we need the next meditation? What are we looking for? What do you mean when you say that? Yeah, I mean by that. So meditation is a wonderful tool for becoming kinder, right? Becoming more compassionate.
但我们不想面对流行病来不得不做出这种修正以找到一种新的寻找幸福的方法。所以你在宗教仪式中看到的是在盘点时期之前。如果你是犹太人，在赎罪日之前的敬畏之日是盘点你生活的时间。如果你是基督徒，是在大斋期，盘点你自己的时间。在每一个之前，对于基督徒来说，有圣灰星期三，这是对你自身死亡的提醒，对吧？牧师实际上把灰烬放在你的头上说，你来自尘土，归于尘土。在犹太新年和赎罪日，犹太人会做一个名为“Moda Ani”的祈祷，它有
But there's other things that we want to do in life, right? How do I become happier? And so, yes, meditation will reduce. anxiety, depression, but how does it find, does it help you find meaning in life? Not exactly. So another thing that people do, you know, if you look at happiness across the lifespan, it tends to drop at its hit its nadir around 40 and 50 and then begins to go up. And there's, there's wonderful evidence from psychologist Laura Carlson that shows that as people age, they turn their desires from kind of wanting to get ahead in life, building skills, you know,
一部分说谁将在来年活着，谁将在来年死去，在他们的时间之前，谁死于火，谁死于剑，谁死于洪水，谁死于瘟疫。今年，那一个确实让人感触很深。而且，它再次提醒你，你在这里的时间，可能不像你想象的那么长。这所做的是它开始改变你的价值观。就像劳拉·卡尔森甚至展示的那样，如果你让老年人说，她说，想象一下你将比你想象的活得更久，因为有一种新药可以帮助你比预期多活20或30年，过上更健康的生活。突然间，他们开始关注技能和他们特有的欲望，就像年轻人一样。所以仅仅这些小小的推动力就很重要。你在这些仪式中看到的是一种帮助我们在应该盘点我们
building status to focus on friends, family, and service, things that actually have been shown to bring more happiness in life. But although it looks like it's a function of age, what her work is really shown is that it's a function of what she calls a time horizon, which is how long I have left until I die. And so what you see in her work and work with other folks is that during pandemics like we've all been facing now, that age difference goes away because suddenly even young people, even people in their 20s and 30s are thinking, I may not have as much time left. And suddenly they look like they're seniors. They are valuing friends, family, finding meaning through service in life.
生活的时候，专注于真正重要的事情，以带来幸福的方法。这就是为什么犹太学者、基督教学者、穆斯林学者都说，你知道，它，它，也不要只等一年一次。你知道，每天，思考我在做什么？而且，你知道，如果我明天看不到，这是我想做的事情吗？所以有很多这样的例子。还有很多其他方法，你知道，人们现在非常热衷于服用迷幻药以获得超越体验。但他们没有采用的也是通常围绕那些超越、那些迷幻药使用的仪式，这些仪式使人们处于生理上的平静和联系状态，以便当那种自我死亡的时刻到来时，它会是愉快的而不是可怕的。
But we don't want to face a pandemic to have to make this kind of correction to find a new way to find happiness. And so what you see in religious rituals is before periods of taking stock. So if you're a Jew during the days of all before Yom Kippur is a time to take stock of your life. If you're a Christian, it's during the period of Lent, a time to take stock of yourself. Before each of those, for Christians, there's Ash Wednesday, which is a reminder of your own mortality, right? The priest actually puts ashes on your head and says, from dust you came and onto dust, you shall return. On Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur, Jews say a prayer called the Moda Ani, which has any. it a part that says who is going to live and who's going to die in their coming year before their
因为现在，你知道，10%到20%的时间，人们在迷幻药上有这些体验，它们是可怕的。它们并不美妙。8%的时间，他们实际上在之后寻求精神科护理。这是因为，正如迈克尔·波伦（Michael Pollan）所说，如果你在那个时刻到来时没有处于正确的精神状态，体验可能会变得非常糟糕。而这些仪式所做的是确保你处于那种心态。所以当我们服用精神活性化学物质并把它们给人们时，通过忽略
time, who by fire, who by sword, who by flood, who by plague. This year, that one kind of hit really hard. And again, it's a reminder that your time here, it may not be as long as you think. And what that does is it begins to shift your values. Like even Laura Carsonson showed that if you make older people say, she said, imagine that you're going to live a lot longer than you thought because there's this new medicine that will help you live a healthier life for 20 or 30 years more than you expected. Suddenly, they start focusing on skills and their idiosyncratic desires as it look like younger people. So just these little nudges can matter. And what you're seeing in these rituals is a way to help us focus at times that we should be taking stock of our
那些使身体和思想处于正确框架的仪式，我们，你知道，增加了事情不会像它们应该的那样顺利的几率。但现在那不必是宗教准备，对吧？我的意思是，现在有心理学家正在用迷幻药做这项工作，他们也会引导人们进行准备，这样当你服用迷幻药时，你就不会像你描述的那样，有一次糟糕的旅行。那是对的。所以如果你看看现在出来的一些最好的研究，来自约翰霍普金斯大学，罗兰·格里菲斯（Roland Griffith）的实验室。
lives on what really matters in ways to bring happiness. And it's why both Jewish scholars, Christian scholars, Muslim scholars have said, you know, it's, it's, don't wait for just once a year either. You know, every day, think about what am I doing? And is, you know, is this what I'd want to do if I weren't going to see tomorrow? So there's lots of examples like that. There's lots of other ways, you know, people now are getting very into taking psychedelics for transcendent experiences. But what they're not adopting is also the rituals that typically surrounded those transcending, those use of psychedelics, which put people in a physiological state of calmness and connectedness so that when that moment of ego death came, it would be pleasurable and not terrifying.
我和那里的人谈过，基本上发生的事情是你是绝对正确的。研究人员花时间和你在一起。他们事先建立那种信任和融洽的关系。他们在过程中和你坐在一起，如果你开始有糟糕的反应，他们会握住你的手。他们会把手放在你的胸口。事后，他们会帮助你理解它。本质上，他们正在做萨满在没有宗教象征意义的情况下会做的事情。
Because right now, you know, 10, 20% of the time, people have these experiences on psychedelics and they're frightening. They're not wonderful. And 8% of the time, they actually seek psychiatric care after. And it's because, as Michael Pollan has said, if you're not in the right state of mind when that moment comes, the experience can go very badly. And what these rituals do is they make sure you're in that frame of mind. So while we're taking the psychoactive chemicals and giving them to people by ignoring
但因为他们让你处于那种平静、信任、与他们有联系的状态，这就是存在的脚手架，有助于确保体验以正确的方式进行。而对于萨满，你会那样做，他或她会帮助引导你。但他们也一起唱这些吟唱，并使用这些鼓点节奏，再次改变人们的呼吸和呼吸频率，让他们感到平静，让他们在发生之前再次感到联系。所以你是对的。你不需要宗教象征意义。
the rituals that put that body and mind in their right frame, where, you know, increasing the odds that things aren't going to go as well as they should. But now that doesn't have to be a religious preparation, right? I mean, there are psychologists who are doing this work right now with psychedelics, and they will also sort of walk people through prepare them so that when you take the psychedelic, you won't have, as you're describing, a bad trip. That's right. So if you look at some of the best research coming out right now is coming from Johns Hopkins, Roland Griffith's Lab.
这就是我在这里试图表达的观点，当我谈到这一点时，人们说，嗯，戴夫，你所说的那不是文化挪用吗？或者如果我是基督徒，为什么我想采用犹太仪式或印度教仪式？我并不赞成文化挪用。我永远不想采用这些仪式并从中获取实际的祈祷、符号和神学意义，因为那些属于起源它们的信仰，应该受到尊重。但它们中有一些元素可以被采用，在人们使用的呼吸中，在他们互动的方式中，在他们唱歌的方式中，在他们生理上互动的方式中。
And I've talked to people there, and what's basically happening is you're absolutely right. The researcher spends time with you. They build that sense of trust and rapport beforehand. They sit with you during it, and if you start to have a bad reaction, they'll hold your hand. They'll put their hand on your chest. And afterward, they will help you make sense of it. In essence, they're doing exactly what a shaman would do without the religious symbology around it.
我和那里的人谈过，基本上发生的情况正如你所说的那样。研究人员会花时间陪伴你，事先建立起信任和融洽的关系。在过程中他们会坐在你身边，如果你开始出现不良反应，他们会握住你的手，或者把手放在你的胸口。事后，他们会帮你理清思绪。本质上，他们所做的正是萨满会做的事，只是去掉了周围的宗教象征意义。
But because they're putting you in that state of calm, trusting, feeling with them, that's the scaffold that is there to help make sure that the experience goes the right way. Whereas with a shaman, you would do that and he or she would help guide you. But they also sing these chants together and use these drumming rhythms that, again, change people's breathing and respiration rates, make them feel calm, make them feel connected again before it happens. So you're right. You don't need the religious symbology.
但正因为他们让你处于那种平静、信任和与他们产生共鸣的状态，这种支撑结构确保了体验能朝着正确的方向发展。而在萨满那里，你也会经历同样的过程，他或她会引导你。但他们还会一起吟唱圣歌，使用鼓点节奏，这些同样能改变人们的呼吸频率，让他们在体验开始前感到平静和联结。所以你是对的，你不需要那些宗教象征。
And that's the point I'm trying to make here, which is when I talk about this, people say, well, Dave, aren't that cultural appropriation what you're saying? Or if I'm a Christian, why do I want to take a Jewish ritual or a Hindu ritual? And I'm not in favor of cultural appropriation. I would never want to take these rituals and take the actual prayers and the symbols and the theological meaning from them because those belong to the face that that originated them and should be respected. But there are elements of them that can be taken in the breathing people use, in the way they interact together, in the way they sing, in the way physiologically that they interact
这就是我想表达的观点。当我谈到这一点时，人们会说，戴夫，你说的这难道不是文化挪用吗？或者如果我是基督徒，我为什么要采用犹太教或印度教的仪式？我并不支持文化挪用。我绝不想窃取这些仪式，也不想拿走其中的祷文、符号和神学意义，因为那些属于创造它们的信仰，应该受到尊重。但其中一些元素是可以借鉴的，比如人们使用的呼吸方式、他们互动的方式、他们歌唱的方式，以及他们在生理上互动的方式。
during prayer, that can be taken and used in a secular context. And, you know, don't just take it for me. those don't belong to any one religion. You see a lot of those things used in multiple religions just with different vocabularies and different theologies and different symbologies. And so my argument is let's learn what they're doing to the body and mind in a secular sense. Put that under the scientific microscope, see when it matters and how we can use that to help people, while respecting, you know, the cultural symbols and theologies of the religions themselves. So we've been talking a lot about how religion can make people happier and provide comfort. But, you know, there's another side of religion as well, which is the threat of punishment, of eternal damnation.
在祈祷过程中，这些方法可以被提取出来并用于世俗语境。而且，你知道，不要只听我的一面之词。这些方法并不属于任何单一宗教。你会发现许多事物在多种宗教中都有应用，只是使用了不同的词汇、神学和象征体系。因此，我的观点是，让我们从世俗的角度去了解它们对身心产生的影响。将其置于科学的显微镜下，看看它们在何时起作用，以及我们如何利用这些方法来帮助人们，同时尊重宗教本身的文化符号和神学。我们一直在讨论宗教如何让人更快乐并提供慰藉。但是，你知道，宗教还有另一面，那就是惩罚的威胁，即永恒的诅咒。
Is that something that you have looked at and is threatening people in that way effective in making them behave ethically? What's happening in your brain when you're being threatened by your religion? Yeah, well, two things there. One, religions can cause guilt and cause shame. And as a psychologist, you study social behavior, I can tell you guilt and shame are extremely motivating and can be very effective in small, brief doses. But used over the long haul are not helpful and cause a lot of pain. And so, again, you know, what I tell people is I'm not an apologist for religion.
你是否研究过这一点？这种威胁人们的方式在促使他们遵守道德行为方面有效吗？当你受到宗教威胁时，你的大脑发生了什么？是的，这里有两点。第一，宗教可能会导致内疚和羞耻感。作为一名研究社会行为的心理学家，我可以告诉你，内疚和羞耻感是非常强大的激励因素，在短时间内可能非常有效。但长期使用则无益，且会造成很多痛苦。所以，我再次重申，我告诉人们，我不是宗教的辩护者。
You know, Steve Pinker and I always get into arguments about this. And he says, Dave, you're cherry picking. There's lots of religion about religion that's bad, right? It causes people guilt and shame. it's perpetuated discrimination, it's caused war and strife. And I'm like, Steve, you're absolutely right. But I am cherry-picking because I want to know what works and what's helpful. I'm not here to defend religion.
你知道，史蒂夫·平克和我总是为此争论不休。他说，戴夫，你在挑拣证据。关于宗教的负面内容有很多，对吧？它导致人们产生内疚和羞耻感，它延续了歧视，引发了战争和冲突。我说，史蒂夫，你说得完全正确。但我确实是在挑拣，因为我想知道什么是有用的、有帮助的。我不是来为宗教辩护的。
And so my argument is if you look at these practices, religion, so take the theology out for a moment. The tools that religion has developed are powerful tools to motivate us, to shape what we feel and do. They can be used for good or for ill. It all depends upon the intentions of the people using it, just like science, right? I mean, Richard Dawkins has said,
所以我的观点是，如果你审视这些实践，即宗教，暂时抛开神学不谈。宗教所发展的工具是强大的激励手段，能够塑造我们的感受和行为。它们既可以用于善，也可以用于恶。这完全取决于使用者的意图，就像科学一样，对吧？我的意思是，理查德·道金斯曾说过，
if you want to find the most efficient way to kill the most people possible, science is your friend. He's right. If you want to find the way to save people from COVID, science is your friend. He's right. I think about religion the same way in the sense that the tools of spiritual practices,
如果你想找到杀伤人数最多的最有效方法，科学是你的帮手。他是对的。如果你想找到拯救人们免受新冠病毒侵害的方法，科学是你的帮手。他是对的。我以同样的方式看待宗教，即精神实践的工具，
I tend to separate from the institutions and the purposes and goals that those institutions have. So yes, religion has caused people lots of pain and cause them to deny science even. But you see that now even with political ideologies, right? We're seeing as a function of political ideology, people deny science when it comes to vaccines and COVID. And so I don't think that's a problem so much of religion
我倾向于将其与这些机构及其目标分离开来。所以是的，宗教确实给人们带来了很多痛苦，甚至导致他们否认科学。但你现在在政治意识形态中也能看到这一点，对吧？我们看到，由于政治意识形态的作用，人们在疫苗和新冠病毒问题上否认科学。所以我认为这不仅仅是宗教的问题，
as a much of ideological institutions. But even if that's what you believe, that it's still worthwhile studying how these tools work so that you can prevent and remediate the problematic aspects of them. Last topic that I want to cover here, talked a little bit about how religious or irreligious Americans are these days. A 2021 Gallup poll found that for the first time since they started polling in the 1940s, less than half of Americans said they belonged to a church, a synagogue, or a mosque. So given your research, what do you think the effects of that will be? Will people be less happy because they're not engaged in religion or less moral? Or are they replacing religion with something else? So it is true, as you said, that people are leaving traditional faith in droves. But the interesting thing is when you look more closely at those data, most of them aren't
而是意识形态机构的问题。但即使这是你的信仰，研究这些工具如何运作仍然是有价值的，这样你才能预防和纠正它们的问题。我想在这里讨论的最后一个话题是，谈谈当今美国人宗教信仰的程度。2021年盖洛普的一项民意调查发现，自20世纪40年代开始民调以来，首次有不到一半的美国人表示他们属于某个教堂、犹太会堂或清真寺。那么，根据你的研究，你认为这会产生什么影响？人们会因为不参与宗教活动而变得不快乐或道德水平下降吗？还是他们正在用其他东西取代宗教？确实如你所说，人们正在成群结队地离开传统信仰。但有趣的是，当你仔细观察这些数据时，大多数人并没有
becoming atheists, right? Most of them are calling themselves nuns, N-O-N-E-S, which is none of the above, right? I'm not Christian. I'm not Jewish. I'm not Hindu. I'm not Muslim. But they're looking for new ways to be spiritual. And I think it's because...
成为无神论者，对吧？他们大多数人称自己为“无宗教信仰者”（Nones），即以上皆非，对吧？我不是基督徒，不是犹太教徒，不是印度教徒，也不是穆斯林。但他们正在寻找新的精神寄托方式。我认为这是因为……
they, in leaving these, these institutions that in some ways, there are good reasons to leave for people, they've failed them. There have been, you know, financial scandals, abuse scandals, gender discrimination. Even sometimes you don't just believe the theology. People recognize that they're leaving behind that sense of community and those tools that help them find meaning and meet the challenges of life. And so I think right now we're going through a time period of people are looking for another way. Now, you know, when Nietzsche said God is dead and we have killed him and, you know, the world's going to fall into chaos, he wasn't right. I mean, you know, we become much more secular. The world isn't full of chaos.
他们在离开这些机构时，虽然在某些方面离开是有正当理由的，因为这些机构辜负了他们。曾出现过财务丑闻、虐待丑闻、性别歧视。有时甚至不仅仅是因为不相信神学。人们意识到他们正在抛弃那种社区感以及那些帮助他们寻找意义和应对生活挑战的工具。所以我认为我们现在正处于一个人们寻找新途径的时期。现在，你知道，当尼采说“上帝已死，我们杀死了他”，并且认为世界将陷入混乱时，他是错的。我的意思是，我们变得更加世俗化了，但世界并没有充满混乱。
You can certainly be a good person without religion. But I do think it fills psychological needs and helps us meet the challenges of life. That is not just the opiate of the mass. It's actually a cultural tool that we've developed to help us meet challenges. And so I do worry a bit that you're going to see declines in well-being that track this leaving of spirituality unless people do find new ways. And to me, that's why I think science needs to take this seriously. If you look at that data, in a dose response framework, people who are more engaged with spiritual practices live longer, healthier, and happier lives. That means, as psychologists, it's our job to figure out why, what are those practices doing?
你当然可以在没有宗教的情况下成为一个好人。但我确实认为它满足了心理需求，帮助我们应对生活的挑战。这不仅仅是“大众的鸦片”。它实际上是我们为了应对挑战而发展出来的一种文化工具。所以我确实有点担心，除非人们找到新的方式，否则你会看到随着这种脱离精神信仰而出现的幸福感下降。对我来说，这就是为什么我认为科学需要认真对待这一点。如果你观察那些数据，在剂量反应框架下，那些更多参与精神实践的人生活得更长寿、更健康、更快乐。这意味着，作为心理学家，我们的工作是找出原因，这些实践到底在起什么作用？
and if people are giving them up, how can we find ways to replace them? And thus the search for the next meditation. Yeah, that's right. Well, Dr. Destano, thank you so much for joining me today. This has been really fascinating. Thank you. Thank you, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spinkingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts.
如果人们放弃了它们，我们如何找到替代方案？因此，寻找下一种冥想方式。是的，没错。好吧，德斯塔诺博士，非常感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的非常引人入胜。谢谢。谢谢你，金。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取最喜爱播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you like us, give us a review. If you have comments for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢我们，请给我们写评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speaking of psychology，连在一起，at apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的音效编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。